I once believed that justice could be
found in a court of law
in the light of day but I was fooling
myself darkness only responds to
darkness para truth is I'd rather die as
the devil than what it was Matt Murdock
everybody is Charlie we finally got our
first official daredevil season 3 teaser
so let's break it down if you're brand
new to the channel we're doing a new
round to that spider-man ps4 giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this reminder - New York Comic Con is
happening the first week in October
daredevil is gonna do a big panel
they'll talk about born again in season
3 they'll reveal an even longer version
of the trailer and there'll be a bunch
of other Marvel stuff happening so it's
gonna be really crazy in a couple of
weeks but the reason why they use this
is the teaser is to give you an idea for
where he is when season 3 picks up and
why he's not going to be Matt Murdock
for most of the season he'll mostly be
going back to the original devil of
Hell's Kitchen persona the reason why
he's in the black costume is is because
Wilson Fisk has been doing everything he
can to slander Matt Murdock's name in
court then at night slandered the name
of the devil of Hell's Kitchen so he
still doesn't know that Matt Murdock is
daredevil yet but he's going after two
enemies that he thinks are two different
people so the reason why he's wearing
the original black costume is is because
Wilson Fisk has dressed somebody up in a
daredevil costume a red one and is going
around killing people making people
think that the devil of Hell's Kitchen
is a criminal to be locked up so it's
just too dangerous for Matt to be
running around in that red costume even
though he still has it the reason why he
quote/unquote wants to die is the devil
like the devil of Hell's Kitchen is is
because he's leaving the Matt Murdock
persona behind because he doesn't
believe in justice anymore the way he
used to like in the inside of a
courtroom
because remember originally at the
beginning of defenders he was ready to
leave the daredevil persona behind and
just be Matt Murdock he helped the kid
get the settlement he had been through
that big thing with Karen page about how
the devil of Hell's Kitchen persona had
torn their group apart and now foggy he
was off by himself she was off at the
newspaper and now he was doing his own
thing so in every heroes arc there's a
moment where he's like I can't be both
the hero the vigilante and the normal
person with a normal life at the same
time so he wanted to be the normal
person but then all the stuff with the
hand happened he had to put a costume
back on and then presumably died even
though we know that he didn't die
everyone else just thinks that he
still dead but on the other side of this
the thing that we have not seen during
the defender season is Wilson Fisk
slowly getting out of prison so the
reason why he doesn't quote-unquote
believe in justice inside a courtroom
anymore is probably because he gets
acquitted of all the charges against him
in court without having to manipulate
everybody the way that he would normally
do so it's one thing when Wilson Fisk
bullies a jury to set him free you kind
of expect a big criminal like the
kingpin to do something like that
manipulating justice or pressuring a
judge threatening their family but the
one thing that would make Matt so pissed
off and stop believing in justice is if
Wilson Fisk did not need to do that like
if he presented all this compelling
evidence that help try to keep him in
prison in the jury still didn't think
that he was guilty of it like letting
him just walk scot-free that would be
one way of breaking Matt Murdock like
obviously the kingpin is gonna try and
physically break him wrap his hands
around them choke the life out of him
but the other side of this coin like we
have bullseye that's coming into season
three he's more of the mercenary version
of bullseye that's working with the FBI
when the season picks up that would be
another perversion of justice is
ostensibly if you have somebody like
that working on the side of justice it
would tip the scales so to speak so
remember daredevil all about the law
justice Catholicism so that's why we're
talking about heaven hell dying is the
devil the devil of Hell's Kitchen if you
haven't read it comic book born-again is
amazing Frank Miller daredevil it's a
total classic they're obviously gonna be
changing some of the story points I
talked about this in a couple of
previous videos but during that
storyline the little bad that's working
underneath the kingpin or that the
kingpin hires is actually nuke who they
kind of burned through in the Jessica
Jones series so they're replacing his
role during Daredevils born-again arc
with bull's eye which is a big upgrade
in my mind the other thing about this is
that obviously Matt woke up at the end
of the defenders in that convent mother
Maggie is his biological mother who he
hasn't really known so a big part of the
season is her giving him guidance the
same way that father Atlanta would when
he's in confessional here so obviously
he's not confessing to his mother that's
the father lanten scene they pick up
almost every single daredevil season
with him and confessional which is why
this is the first official
teaser with him in confessional saying
look darkness only responds to darkness
so I'm going to bring the devil during
season 3 so they just want to let you
know the daredevil at least for part of
the season is gonna go on a tear it's
gonna be hard core so if you've been
upset the daredevil has not got a new
season in a couple of years
I mean I'll explain why it's logically
makes sense the timeline that they
wanted but because the production on
defenders brought all the other shows to
a grinding halt because the main stars
had to all be on the same show that's
really the reason why everything got
delayed but making more religious
metaphors matt has like a angel and the
devil on his shoulder and he's mostly
listening to the devil in this clip here
mother Maggie is probably gonna be the
angel on his shoulder that gives him the
wisdom he needs to come back and learn
to be Matt Murdock again and the devil
of Hell's Kitchen remember like I said
like if you watch any superhero TV show
when it goes a couple years the arc is
is that he's the vigilante but then it
destroys his personal life and he finds
out that he can't be both those personas
at the same time but then eventually
with the help of his friends or any
trusted adviser figures finds a way to
balance those two lives and becomes more
well-rounded superhero by the end of the
series so the whole idea now is that the
kingpin has destroyed Matt Murdock's
life so he only has the devil of Hell's
Kitchen to fall back on but eventually
he'll become a more actualized version
of daredevil that the city isn't trying
to shoot down at every site because
remember kingpin has that fake version
of daredevil running around killing
people
and this newspaper here is Karen pages
newspaper so it sounds like kingpin is
gonna send this fake daredevil after
Karen page in the comics kingpin sent
the fake daredevil after foggy Nelson I
think they're playing the Karen page car
just because she seems a little more
vulnerable and even though she has been
with Punisher for a while it seems like
right now he's off doing his own thing I
don't expect him to appear maybe a
teaser clip at the end of the season the
same way that they attached this
daredevil teaser to the end of iron fist
so if you're wondering this daredevil
clip has absolutely nothing to do with
what happens during iron fist it's
literally just a daredevil season 3 clip
that they copy pasted onto the end of
iron fist episode 10 so I've already
posted my non-spoilery iron fist season
2 review i'll link that at the end of
this but there is a whole
of comic-book stuff that happens towards
the end of the season and because of all
that comic book stuff I am wondering if
daredevil season three which is already
doing a lot of comic book stuff puts
Matt in the black costume from shadow
land instead of say the red costume
again at the end of the series or the
yellow costume like if he goes from the
original black costume to wearing a
version of the black costume that has
the armor like his red version of the
costume will pay another visit to stilt
man to see what he's up to but just
remember season three of daredevil is
all about the rise of the kingpin so if
you've been waiting for a Wilson Fisk
that's a little bit more like comic book
kingpin I think we'll get there by the
end of the season because like Luke Cage
is the king of Harlem now I can't really
talk about the end of Iron Fist without
spoilers but like all the heroes are
sort of rising to power on all their TV
shows which obviously implies that the
kingpin will be slowly taking over all
of the city's territory so I think by
the time we get to season four of
daredevil and I definitely think there
will be a season four he'll be a little
bit more like the kingpin you see during
spider-man ps4 if you ever played that
game kingpin is like the first big boss
that you face what's going on later
today is there were a whole bunch of
trailers that drop there's new
spider-man into the spider-verse
there was another interview because of
all that Captain Marvel stuff that
dropped where they reveal the Captain
America is definitely leaving the
franchise so I'll do a Captain America
Avengers 4 video next that should be up
in a little while but congratulations
mic schlager you're the latest giveaway
winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel click here for that Captain
Marvel teaser and click here for that
Iron Fist non-spoilery review thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight